le chirurgien se prépare l'intervention
consiste ici à éliminer les calculs
rénaux d'un jeune homme ces petits
cristaux contenus dans les urines qui
peuvent grossir et provoquer des
douleurs très intenses pour un homme
c'est une des douleurs les plus
importantes qui peut vivre puisqu'on
compare c'est la douleur de la colique
néphrétique donc la maladie que cause
les calculs à la douleur d'un
accouchement sans anesthésie pour
extraire les calculs il va utiliser une
chirurgie moins agressive dite mini
invasive grâce à une mini caméra et de
la lumière qu'on peut insérer dans le
corps à l'aide de petits tuyaux le
chirurgien peut aller chercher et
retirer les calculs en passant par la
verge voilà donc là on est dans le canal
de l'urètre
on fait en passant un petit coude et on
se retrouve dans la vessie vous voyez
j'irai avec de l'eau lorsque les calculs
sont trop gros le chirurgien peut même
les pulvériser directement dans le corps
grâce à cette fibre laser d'une taille
minuscule de 260 microns et le calcul
vient rebondir sur la fibre laser et il
se suicide quoi c'est l'effet pop-corn
à chaque fois qu'il retouche la sonde il
perd un petit grain et nous on voit
cette petite poudre blanche apparaître
quoi
quelques minutes plus tard
l'intervention est terminée les calculs
du génome sont tous éliminés il va
pouvoir sortir d'ici deux trois heures
dans les conditions de la chirurgie
ambulatoire moi il y a 20 ans quand
j'apprenais la chirurgie avec mes
maîtres de chirurgie je les voyais faire
prendre un bistouri et faire une
incision de 10 cm pour des calculs que
je traite maintenant sans avoir du tout
à faire d'incision quoi il y a plus du
tout d'incisions donc c'est mini
invasive dans la mesure où on rentre
jusqu'au bout de l'intérieur du corps de
quelqu'un mais sans aucun dommage
corporel si je puis dire parce que
l'incision ça reste un dommage qu'on a
le droit de causer au patient la
chirurgie mini invasive dont le matériel
coûte cher et nécessite de lourds
investissements et l'un des axes majeurs
de la Clinique Saint Louis à Poissy
atténuer les douleurs éviter des séjours
prolongés aux patients deux atouts déjà
important pour autant l'accompagnement
post-opératoire n'est pas à négliger il
s'agit pas d'opérer la personne de se
dire voilà on est très content
on a fait une intervention mini invasive
elle peut sortir derrière il faut
accompagner ce patient jusqu'à son
retour à domicile pour que lui permettre
aussi de maintenir une qualité de vie et
de pas l'abandonner voilà en cours de
route dans l'établissement la chirurgie
mini-invasive est également pratiquée
sur le pied les hémorroïdes